what was that weird thing going on
between you and Ronnie yesterday Gary
what happened you got on the wrap-up
show we're talking about the dinner we
went to level with JD and John and
Ronnie and I just said that I thought
ronnie was acting a little weird that
night it was almost like we were still
on the air it was just kind of
surprising to me because I was looking
at talk to Ronnie but I think he was
being he was very wild up that night
well all I know is he was listening to
that and he was like I don't know what
Gary's talking about Ronnie was on fire
in the car he was like so he got riled
up because of what Gary said Ronnie what
was it we learned yesterday that you
made Gary young I didn't misunderstand
anything I heard exactly what he said
what do you say he said that I thought I
kind of made him uncomfortable like he
wasn't wanted there I love your accent
but ever want to do well we were out to
dinner I felt strange with Ronnie it
didn't feel comfortable in other words
he wasn't talking to you
no I felt like he was kind of like just
kind of performing well I apologized to
if I make it uncomfortable Wow when he
walked back from the wrap-up show he
said I'm really sorry for making you
uncomfortable I know but it was it
busted my balls right just fine so you
don't want to go out with him anymore no
I do yeah we're gonna go out are you
gonna go to his birthday party the Jays
got a birthday birthday party the
biggest problem for me is yeah if you
might drop dead don't have a birthday
yeah it got moved from a Friday to a
Saturday night and I bought the tickets
and didn't mention to Mary so I told her
about it last night and she just goes I
[ __ ] hate jazz why don't you all just
admit you [ __ ] hate jazz and go
somewhere fun why are you torturing
yourselves
I actually thought to something brand a
nose idea well he's an idiot why are you
listening to him I'm not listening to me
it doesn't [ __ ] would you like why are
you putting yourself through that cuz
it's to eat Steve what kind of plays
cool yeah no it's cool
Charlie Mingus porkpie hat
some check you guys take orders from
Steve Brandon I'm not taking orders do
something fun I'm not taking orders he
said we're all going would you like to
join us
yeah Steve why would you why would you
suggest the jazz club nobody really
likes jazz not in this group I hear what
you're saying yeah why would you like if
I have one night free I'm not gonna go
somewhere where I kind of don't like it
Ronnie and I hang a lot during the
mornings while we're waiting for the
guests Ronnie and I spend a lot of time
together nowadays it was a weird day
where I was listening to piano music in
the green room and Ronnie came in and
was like you like this stuff and I was
like yeah you like this stuff and he was
like I've been to jazz clubs how did you
decide who should go to Ronnie party
there you left a lot of people I said I
would love to do this with you I know
your birthday is coming up right I don't
want to make this a thing about me well
you're glad would you like to do this
and he said yes yeah that was a lot of
people are feeling left out of this
group out sorry what are you gonna do I
know I know one person who I are Richard
I think Richard I would I would blow you
to be left out of that Jon Gary JD who
usually hang out with Ronnie and said I
am perfectly happy to go with just
Ronnie and I and we'll find a night to
do it if you guys would like to do this
you really enjoy hanging out with Ronnie
for this I do
Wow and also I said and I would love if
we could keep this to at least going to
it before it gets to on air but that
cats out of the bag and now you will
goof on us for what is just a cool fun
night of going out cool Steve Brandon oh
and Ronnie hanging out sounds like maybe
the most horrible thing I've ever heard
of why it just sounds like a nightmare
certainly
so cool what cool hang Gary you little
leave that group they don't want you
there anyway I'm kind of getting that
[Music]